federal prosecutors say they're
considering charging the 21 year old
white man arrested in the deadly el paso
shopping center rampage with hate crimes
and Firearms charges and they're looking
at the case as domestic terrorism we are
also treating this as a domestic
terrorist case there's a statutory
definition of domestic terrorism in 18
USC 2 3 3 1 this meets it it appears to
be designed to intimidate a civilian
population to say the least we are
treating it as a domestic terrorism case
and we're going to do what we do to
terrorists in this country which is
deliver Swift and certain justice the
suspect apparently posted a racist rant
online shortly before the shootings
Texas prosecutors will also charge
Cruces the chart the state charge is
capital murder and so he is eligible for
the death penalty
El Paso Police say the rifle allegedly
used in the killings was purchased
legally
the suspect is cooperating with
investigators so you know uh forthcoming
with information uh he basically didn't
hold anything back meanwhile more than
two dozen people wounded in the attack
were being treated some in critical
condition they received a variety of
procedures from a number of different
specialties some of them undergoing
procedures by multiple specialties
during the same setting
we anticipate that a number of the
patients will need to return to the
operating room over the course of today
in the next week perhaps one or more
times flags flew at half-staff outside a
school where relatives gathered to get
word about missing loved ones from
officials El Paso sits on the US Mexican
border and citizens of both countries
frequently cross back and forth mexico's
foreign minister says nine Mexican
citizens were shot if Saturday was a day
of violence and terror for many el paso
ins sunday was a day to mourn and to
pray
at Cielo Vista church not far from the
scene of the massacre people gathered to
worship support each other and seek
answers we try to give labels to things
that shouldn't be labels like we're all
here if we're all Americans we're all
Americans were nothing but not Mexican
American black American African America
we're just American we as a church are
going to a band together hold each other
together and pray for one another and
just believe the best greater days ahead
praying for better times after one of
this community's most terrible days rob
reynolds al jazeera el paso